Now you may notice that some of these points are spread
out from one another, while others are stacked right on top of
each other. This area of the graph is considered to be over
plotted. Over plotting makes it difficult to tell how many points are
in each region. So we can set the transparency of the
points using the alpha parameter and geom point. I'm going to add this
on a new line so that we can see our layers more
clearly. Next I set the alpha parameter equal to 1 over 20.
So this means it's going to take 20 points to
be the equivalent of one of these black dots. Writing
this code, we can see that the bulk of our
data lies below the 1000 threshold for friend count. Now
let's also add a little jitter here too. We can
swap out geom_point with the geom_jitter. Age is a continuous
variable but you really only have integer values, so we
are seeing these perfectly lined up columns. Which isn't a
true reflection of age. These columns should feel intuitively wrong
and we want to make sure that we can see more
of the points. So using jitter we can add some
noise to each age so we get a clearer picture
of the relationship between age and friend count. Writing our
code with geom_jitter we can see that we get a
more disperse distribution. What stands out to you in this
new plot? Keep in mind that the alpha is set to
120th or 0.05.